leone tavares leads off in center field
tavares swings on the second pitch and
laces one down into the left field
corner with tavares speed he'll easily
have a lead-off double and here's kind
of left with the rangers leading hitter
against lefties
bouncer down to third base that'll get a
run home the throw to first in time but
ikf picks up his ninth rbi and the
rangers plate the first run of the game
wes benjamin on the mound tonight for
his first major league start and here's
the pitch breaking ball swung on and
missed
nifty curve to get walker
the o2
that one in there strike three called
and he gets calhoun looking so a
shutdown inning for west benjamin
this year he's made six starts 14 games
he's been in though
[Applause]
swinging a miss change up from alex
young he gets his first dragon
[Applause]
kind of like that three straight
changeups gets his second strikeout
we'll count three and two there goes
calhoun swinging a miss so young strikes
out the side so huff steps up huff
struck out
in the second this one out to right
field struck well gets down in the alley
and goes to the wall huff will have
extra bases
cruises to second base the big fella in
there with a one out double yeah when he
hits it he really hits it here comes
anderson tajeda now he's struck out in
the second
this one hit up the middle that's a base
hit it gets huffed to the plate
tajeda's eighth rbi of the year and it's
a two-nothing ball game
apostle is swinging a miss
for strikeout for young ncaa one run on
two-inch seman left calhoun the reigning
national league player of the week
had hits in all six of those games that
streak snapped yesterday
the one-two hit on the ground right side
and flagged down by apostle he'll flip
to benjamin leads him to the bag
properly and benjamin gets there ahead
of calhoun
ground ball third base counterfeit left
at a second one solac returned it to
first double play inning over first walk
allowed today by alex young and that
brings up counterfeit
this one out to right field that's a
base hit and more for connor falefa
solac can run they'll wave him around
third base it won't even be close kinder
philippa going for three
and he will pull in with an rbi triple
three nothing rangers in the fifth
it's a strike yellow looking
is uh caught for a strikeout number five
for young one out now for mathis it is 0
for one
[Applause]
wyatt matheson sends one deep to left
field wyatt matheson it's gone his first
major league home run
seven games into his big league career
wyatt matheson is on the board
and so are the diamondbacks it's three
to one congratulations to wyatt matheson
oh my gets a change up right in the
middle of the strike zone
he strikes him out anyways walker chases
strike three the inning is done one and
two to sam huff
one two pitch grounded down to third and
that one skips past into left field that
should be extra bases for hoff
back to back doubles for sam huff
what a ball game he's having here is the
shortstop anderson to hayden
here comes huff walker coming home
got him at the plate they cut down the
run
and it stays three to one very much
under control there by christian walker
he knew he had time all he needed to do
was make an accurate throw to home plate
and they're going to get the out there
two runners in scoring position for
carson kelly
base it for carson kelly escobar scores
here comes calhoun carson kelly a
two-run single and we are tied at three
going a chance for dalton farcio
varshall slams it into right center
that's gonna get to the wall carson
kelly being waved around third dalton
varsios
an rbi triple and it's four three
diamondbacks
still only one out he's 90 feet away
from matheson who homered his last time
up
matheson does he have one more
wyatt matherson
to advance his first two major league
home runs there's a day to remember for
wyatt matheson 26 year old rookie home
runs numbers one and two and it's six to
three now if tim lacastro hits a double
in this at bat they will in a span of
four banners have hit for the cycle in
the second consecutive sixth inning
skies it to deep left field
white's at the wall castro sends one out
of here
they go back to back make it seven three
diamondbacks
could tell martay now
tavares won't get to that one and martay
finds a gap but gets to the wall kettel
thinking three all the way
and he's gonna get in there with an easy
triple i'm in back second triple in this
hitting
crown ball third what a diving stop by
kinder philippa and he
throws out
escobar c-backs in position for the
two-game sweep
walker's got it crichton gets over there
d-backs take both games against the
rangers
he wanted last night seven nothing and
they win this one 7-3